[Music]
my gosh you look fantastic
always events I've been very well
gorgeous my goodness you look beautiful
in pink Thanks I love the ring and
earrings to go by there too nice touches
that have you been good how about you
well I'm excited to be here tonight lily
and I are both nominated you're gonna
know we love each other so Grayson
Frankie yeah / Grayson Frankie as it
should be thank you when you guys heard
the nomination what was your reaction oh
we drank a lot of champagne and yelled
and screamed we were in the middle of
shooting our fourth season and everybody
was very excited dolly is here tonight
as well yes I know we're gonna be seeing
her and co-presenting with her maybe
yeah should I not admit that already I'm
glad that you did I think we got a
little I had a time secret yeah I'm
gonna blast that out everywhere right
now it's awesome because that's what
we've all been talking about all week is
that okay are we gonna have a little 9
to 5 reunion reunion that's right it's
gonna be good last year we were thinking
maybe there might be a little bit of
wine but I know that you were a little
under weather I lost my boys but I'm
here today what we're we're so excited
about thanks good to see you there
possibility there might ever be a you
everybody loves nostalgia these days is
there a chance there's gonna be a
nine-to-five sequel in the future or get
together or something I don't think so
why not Jane it's too complicated and
boring to sit on a night like this maybe
we'll have a reunion in some other way
on screen but not in a sequel to
nine-to-five like maybe dolly would be a
guest on the show maybe she would call
my grace and break those who knows
I think she might we're hoping I know
good to see ya I got to know who the
jewels are bye though first we tell me
who the jewels that you why I don't know
but they're fabulous I know they were
flown from Geneva today
dat tell me so I can't answer those
questions right now but we'll get back
to you well I like it I used to it's not
real I used to have hair this long but
not anymore I liked it a lot thanks
having done all the red carpets you've
done what are your secrets to attacking
the red carpet I watched what Gwen
Stefani does on a red carpet and try to
copy her and that's the truth
it doesn't come naturally to me but she
doesn't so great so I try to do what she
does so you're Gwen Stefani inspired
right what's one thing you do to
celebrate when it's over I drink
martinis
[Music]